die bio-europe wieder halten schnauzte
kriegst du niemals sagt sag bitte sag
bitte ganz nett bitte gib mir op bitte
gib mir hey leute und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge von
der app idriver ersten verhör bei mir
auf dem kanal zusammen mit dem ur
menschen schlechthin hier den steinwald
steinwald steinfeld minecraft freunde du
bist ein jump'n'run fail und du hast
heute eine face kathrin habe ich gehört
und ich hab's geschafft und ich habe
eine aktive junge start-up ist die leute
ich sagt vor der karte nicht bieten und
so ganzen scheiß machen und kommt dann
auf ihn und deutet das war meine schuld
ist das geschehen aber die karte heißt
nicht ohne grund
nein da bist wir kommen wir müssen hier
hoch den sandstein entlang der kommen
richtig angekommen können direkt komm
komm lass deinen frust freien lauf ich
will dich nicht selbst teleportieren
eigentlich marktwert müsste so rum sein
dass ich hier frust habe weil ich hab
noch keine gasttrainer gefunden
wieder halt die schnauze kriegst du
niemals über das wie das ist nicht gut
das kann man ihm halt die fresse
ja okay doch ich geb dir op aber dann
hör ich habe mich nicht wie es bruder
okay ich gebe jetzt auch dachte gerade
die karten bmw opel genommen bitte gib
mir drauf so was euch den halt dein maul
als nichtig weil ich würde ich kaum noch
zwischen ich krieg dich gleich drei
wünsche okay wo geht's lang
lol was an denn ihr habt mir den level
löffel gekrallt hier
das konnten hier raus nach goldene äpfel
und bananen banane beinamen drin was
wollen diese ganzen schweiz schaffe
schaffe die heißt in der endlos also
dass die wahl kommt muss man ja noch
einmal logisch denken mannschaften das
auch hier so und wie ist es soweit
ersichtlich mit terroristen
ganze fahrspuren geholt wenn sportportal
also nee leute erst ab etwa bei diesen
trolling king hier dem komma hd yahia
löw hat wird auch wieder morgen bei ihm
seine kenntnis der wahrscheinlich noch
von laptop und danach kommt wir der
vierte partie bei dir richtig und
lichter crazy dungeon jump on the
pressure play together juni zur content
in uk komme hast du eigentlich wieder
schule warum weil sie durch ich wollte
fragen weil ich hab noch ferien 8
also ich meine das leben ist eine schule
halt dein maul lebens ferien jetzt
schalter jung ich laufe ja aus und sucht
nach typischen schlecht schlechter
stelle schlechter stelle als schlecht
ich gebe halt auf die druckplatte ersten
löffel jetzt löffelt cool aber in dem
vertrauen gegeben dass du mich damit
nicht tot ist
junge junge ohne witz ich brauche was er
hasst du hast du ein
jetzt hast du redstone fackel oder so
dann kann ich dann einfach so ich hab
ein hebel einmal brauchen wir für später
wenn wir den ich mir abbauen können und
der verschwindet aber ich brenne getötet
oder unschuldig kämpfe ja ich erwarte
hier erstmal noch ganz gut leben
ganz professionell
ich bin wieder ganz am anfang ja das ja
geil ich kenne die geile teppich trug
die ganze ohne op scheiße ich hatte echt
übels am anfang
hier kommen weißt du ich bin ein böser
hat er hortet jetzt also wie es wohl
auch nur lange alter ich habe gerade
nach gast reden geschaut hab ich auch
schon hier oben hier ist nichts
er war aber eine so kommen jetzt rein
hier komm rein hier komm rein kommen
weil ich eigentlich zwei schaffen
das äußert ruhe das tor ja noch alle
zwei eigentlich nur eine gefühlen und
die bitte nicht ich auf die druckplatte
nicht hier rausgehen okay nicht auch oft
gehe nicht darum nicht daran dass gerade
eine erfahrungspunkte auf die
druckplatte qin gang
dadurch wird ihr körper des board hib
ich bäume an bord nicht noch mal junge
du bist bei mir wo du siehst der kleine
zu messen wenn hin
ich hoffe dass auch das haus daraufhin
die oder doch nicht
oder den werken einfach doch wir müssen
hier hoch check point and important tore
habe ich das gemacht ich hab die meisten
gefehlt da und du schreibst einfach mal
die gas drehen
hier kommt drauf
ja geil geil auf jeden fall
ich höre hier klug und versteckt sich
dahinter um solche idee komme ich gar
nicht aber mal ohne flachs wissen wir
hierhin
ich weiß gar nicht wo geht damit wäre
ich finde ja überhaupt kein weg man
erwarte vielleicht muss man vom balkon
die unternehmer wären die andere
richtung vielleicht auch auf jeden fall
müssen wir glaube ich erst mal auf die
andere seite springen
aber die von ihr kommen wir ja du bist
so klug wie immer ich glaube wir müssen
da sogar ein oder nähen lassen einfach
den berg hoch wachsen vielleicht müssen
wir wirklich den weg kraxeln aber doch
nicht da oben stand auf dem schild
nothing to sea also wenn man es gut
obwohl steht gut shop das soll ja daria
genommen da habe ich meine erste gas
trainer ehrlich ja ich bin stolz drauf
junge da bin ich sogar vor hinterher
gelaufen und stand up for oder mich
dabei nicht eingegangen den raum
hier kann man irgendwie lange aber ob
man hier richtig ist seht ihr wenn das
licht angeht kommen wir versuchen
einfach mal rein zu gehen vielleicht
sind ja noch irgendwelche hinweise
finden auf dem haus hier links hier
vorne da oben auf dem haus da müssen wir
auf dauer bettruhe drauf sehe ich von
hier
das sind ruhe drauflos wie kommen wir da
oben auf dein haus drauf also auf das
was du bist ja oft ein haus es hat heute
dein haus ich bin drauf achtlos bei gas
drehen
ich habe junge danke dass du mir das
gesagt hast du blöd
bitte holen ich hoffe dass nena da waren
nicht im ernst zwei ganz junge ich hätte
so etwas nie gesagt wenn ich eine kiste
gesehen hätte
ich bin viel zu ausgeklügelter für
sigrid bett ja du hast dich auch
wirklich angestrengt weil er auch so und
ort also wirklich respekt als ich das
modell gedanke klar man auch mal sagen
dass er die alle smartphone you're not
allowed to break anything in die top 10
ist das richtig ja geil ich fahr runter
geil geil
du wartest du auf mich ein bisschen
heftig de abonniert ich jetzt okay ich
warte ich war natürlich aber moment mal
bist du ein minecraft freundin bist du
kein minecraft freuen
ich bin in minecraft freund der dann
darfst du nicht abonnieren
ich bin und du bist du ein fehler ich
bin beim ersten sprung nicht irgendwann
war auch eine fiese wand oben einfach da
flippte was vor check point to bed ok
nich mal bitte ich habe es geschafft
nicht ins wasser zu woche truppe willst
du dir gar nicht bei mir damals heftige
heute das unsichtbar bei mir erwartet
beck nein ja egal dann will dich einfach
jawohl ich hab dich geschlagen hat
jemand ein remix gemacht
dollar ddp ddp
ich glaube es nicht schafft es ist echt
und fassbar kultur new opel halten
schnauzte bitte einmal drogen ist
verdorben
da guckt er einmal zu gucken einmal habe
ich schon oft genug hat einmal alter
zwei frauen hören willst du ohne zu
lachen ich hole mir jetzt gas dreht sich
um drei grad drehen gefunden
ohne scheiß ohne scheiß fünf stück man
kann das nicht schaffen
na ja spaß bestätigte zusammen runter er
warte warte mal kurz leute man kann das
nicht schaffen ich springe ich hab mich
auf meinen namen gibt es die realen das
wie hast du das gemacht mich erst mal
schlafen dann bist du darunter
gesprungen oder sprinten und dann aber
daher bei springer springen also schaden
ist noch dabei hinten und springen das
ist ein super tipp alter komm schon mal
zurückkommt dir das an das ist unmöglich
das ist halo zu tricksen passauer ja
wien endlich mal wieder bin komplett mit
wenn du schaffst gebe ich gerne gas
treten wenn du mir zeigst es geht
okay man springt ja geil geil geil so
geht man mit einem normalen sprung raus
springen und dann moment genau so zu
spricht sogar die golfbälle auf jeden
fall
ich muss schon sagen das machst du echt
stark selbst die schweine meint du bist
ja ich weiß auch gar nicht wo du wie du
hier auf gekommen bist man kommt der
normalerweise von der oberfläche weiß
deswegen bin ich doch die ganze zeit
runter sei hier auf ja und dann hier
sind lauter aber man muss einfach nur
laut und beim anfangs shift drücken
ja so naiv oder easy going und dann hier
auf sie und dann passt auf man hat hier
jede decke über eine ich hab's geschafft
so komm mal drauf so und jetzt stelle
ich hier mit ich hin
schonach da unten und dann springt man
den gleichen moment springen
danke durch sprint ist nicht aber ich
hab' ich schwöre ich bin gespannt die
leute bei mir nicht schwere beute
doch jahr in die sprung habe ich
vielleicht vergessen aber ich weiss
essen die folge schon flammen gefängnis
waren okay probiert jetzt noch einmal
probiert so langweilig dass ein affe
holt habe warte auf mich gome hd oder
ich mache das komme hd in goma es gebe
jetzt muss ich diese pläne gerade so
böse pläne
wobei hier wie da beide leiter das
mitleid habe ich jetzt geschafft
ok ok milkshake ich hab's geschafft
jetzt warte man ganz kurz ja klar ich
bin hier oben auf der plattform sage ich
mal wo auch die ganzen betten
hauptstellen aber bisher noch lange
nicht dass mit diesen geschafft ich
komme gleich vorbei kollege ich trete ja
weil ich kaum noch warum
und jetzt bringt er nicht ich denke wenn
du nicht sprinten kannst dir das einfach
an
ok so bin da einfach in einem durchlauf
gemacht dass der gold kupfer sagt ja
solar das ist ja geil sagte zack zack
zack und trüben
wie hast du denn den blauen geschafft
dass es bei mir nie zu weit war ich
schaffe das
sag mal wie lange hast dich keine
sprünge machte minecraft warten wenn ich
außer übung doch ja ich hab's geschafft
repsol in ich bin hinter dir jetzt komme
ich bin dein vater prüfer hier ist auch
die worte gefallen
durchgefallen egal wir sagen jetzt
einfach geil so ok das noch mal schlafen
gehen und dann kannst du mit der mit dem
plättchen hier in die folge beenden
zunächst falsches links falsches eine
banane ja ok freunde ich würde sagen das
war's mit der zweiten folge ich auf
meinem kanal die dritte folge gibt man
bekomme wenn es euch gefallen hat würden
wir definitiv einen daumen hoch ein wenn
euch diese tablets gesteckt sondern
still sprüche wir freuen uns dann aufs
nächste mal wieder einschalten in bombay
kommen genau haute reinschauen